اسقطت اكثر رؤساء امريكا اثاره للجدل
بفضيحه دفع لها 130 الف دولار كي تصمت
لكنها لم تفعل رغم زعمها تلقيها تهديدات
بالقتل فلماذا مماثله الافلام الاباحيه
تقول انها فخوره برؤيه ترامب يواجه
العداله بعدما وجهت هيئه المحلفين في
نيويورك لائحه اتهاما له من ضمنها شراء
صمتها عن علاقه اقامتها معه عام 2006
تقارير كشفت ان اعتبر الترشح ترامب في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2016 فرصه
ذهبيه لفضح هذه العلاقه اما تبريرها لعدم
التزامها باتفاق الصمت الذي تصفه بالباطل
ايضا لان ترامب لم يوقعه بيده بل محاميه
مايكل كوهين وبالتالي فهي ليست ملتزمه به
سرمي قالت في تصريحات سابقه للصيانات انما
فعلته بترامب فتح باب الاعمال لديها
والاهتمام بها بشكل اكبر مراقبون يقولون
ان الممثله استثمرت جيدا الفضيحه لصالحها
فنشرت مذكراتها التي عنونتها بالافصاح
التام وتساقطت عليها العروض من مجلات وصحف
امريكيه لبيع قصتها والحديث عن تفاصيل ذلك
اليوم